الأجنبية
هي واحدة من أكثر المناطق
إثارة للجولف في العالم ويصادف عام 2022
الذكرى السنوية الخامسة والعشرين لأعظم ذكرى جولف في إسبانيا
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن الكأس النادرة كانت ضخمة ليس
فقط لفالاراما ولكن لتحت روفيا وبالنسبة
لإسبانيا كانت بداية
أصبحت منطقة الأندلس هذه وجهة ذهبية حقيقية
في عام 1997 ، حيث تم لعب كأس رايدر خارج
أمريكا أو الجزر البريطانية
لأول مرة في تاريخها
، وحقق الفريق الأوروبي بقيادة كابتنهم الأيقوني
نصف باليستيروس
أحد أشهر الانتصارات في تاريخ الحدث.
وساعدت في إحداث طفرة في
المشاركة في هذه الرياضة عبر إسبانيا ،
لم يقل أحد في العائلة ، ولا
والداي أو والدتي ، على والدي
أن تطأ قدمه على ملعب للجولف حتى
جربه والدي والسبب الوحيد الذي
فعله كان بسبب  97 كأس رايدر في
إسبانيا ، كانت مجموعة من أصدقائه
في مكان ما في جنوب إسبانيا
وسمعوا عنها ثم ذهبوا وشاهدوها
، لذا يا له من حدث لا يصدق
وكانوا كذلك.  دعنا نحاول الحصول
عليها هنا في Balarama ، لقد كانت لحظة رائعة
ربما كانت أكبر لحظة في
اجتياح إسبانيا ، مثّل مانويل
بينيرو فريق أوروبا في
كأس رايدر 1981 و 1985 وكان أحد
أقرب أصدقاء Savvy byesteros
وكان بينيرو مقعدًا في الصف الأمامي
تعرف على ما جعل سيفي قائدًا تعويذيًا
وشخصية ملهمة في لعبة الجولف
الأوروبية نمت بشكل كبير في إسبانيا منذ
97 مع إلهام سافي المشجعين
لتولي اللعبة وتحويل الرياضة إلى
واحدة من التسلية المفضلة في البلاد ،
كأس رايدر كان ذلك الوقت هو
ثالث أكبر حدث رياضي
في العالم ، كانت الجماهير
متحمسة حقًا لرؤيته في ملعب الجولف ، لقد
جلب الكثير من الناس إلى ملعب الجولف ،
لقد جذب الكثير من الاهتمام
إلى لعبة الجولف ، أعتقد حقًا
أنه بدون تشيفي
نحن  كان من الممكن أن يستغرق
20 أو 30 عامًا أكثر
لنصل إلى ما نحن عليه اليوم ، ليس لدي أي شيء سوى أقصى درجات الاحترام والإعجاب لـ Savvy byesteros ، هذا
كل ما يمكنني
قوله  لقد كان رائدًا في لعبة الجولف ، ليس فقط في
إسبانيا ولكن في أوروبا كما تعلم ،
وعندما أخبر الناس أنك
تصدقني عادةً عندما بدأ لعب الجولف
، أعتقد أنه كان هناك حوالي 15000 شخص
لديهم رخصتهم للعب الجولف في
إسبانيا عندما كان  مات هناك 350000
شخص
شكرا لك
أجنبي